nein es gibt keine illegalen stimmen
wenn sie rechtzeitig abgestempelt wurden
und wenn das jeweilige bundesstaats
recht sagt dass sie eben noch am
nächsten tag noch zwei tage noch 357
tage in north carolina noch zwölf tage
eingehen würden und dann sind das
stimmen die zu zählen sind dass das
donald trump anders sieht in seiner welt
und sagt nee was am wahltag nicht da war
das zelt nicht dass sich sozusagen seine
interpretation die ihr ja versucht
juristisch durchzusetzen und damit
scheitert er momentan aber die sender
die ihn abgeschaltet haben wir haben
eigentlich einen gefallen getan denn
trump anhänger halten nun diese medien
wörtlich für ein parteiisches instrument
der demokratischen partei das vertrauen
in die medien in den usa ist sowieso im
boden das ist noch weit unter dem
vertrauen das sie in die präsidentschaft
haben und daran kann sich jetzt die
channel und sagen siehste genauso geht
es mir wenn ich die wahrheit sagen will
nehmen die mir ein saft weg der tonband
abgestellt und das ergebnis ist dass 30
prozent seiner anhänger jetzt zu
protokoll geben dass sie der ansicht
sind der präsident hat recht mehr
nachrichten und breaking news nur bei
bate schau dich hier das nächste video
an und vergiss nicht zu abonnieren